are you ever on tick tock or instagram
and you see a post or an ad for a
product
and you're like i want to buy that but
it's probably bad and then you scroll
past and are forever left wondering what
could have been
well wonder no more because today i'm
going to be putting those things to the
test
over the last few weeks i've ordered a
bunch of cooking products that i saw
advertised on tiktok to see whether
they're worth your time and more
importantly
your hard-earned money or your stimulus
checks
[Music]
so first up we have the zip slicer
so the idea here is that you fill up
this tube with cherry tomatoes or grapes
and then you take this and you just
and it slices all of those in half
seems fun pretty simple concept but i
think we have to see if it works
let's load this bad boy up
and then i just take this
do you just dump them out okay
then you're left with a nicely sliced
pile of cherry tomatoes let me try
grapes this time
zip zip soup yeah that worked well
this is definitely a little bit faster
and it may be a little bit safer if
you're wary of using a knife and it's
kind of just fun to use
i mean if you're shopping up a lot of
cherry tomatoes or grapes and you like
things like this then
yeah i'd say this one for 13 bucks
not a bad buy
so next up we have the hutzler banana
slicer
this seems like a joke a few years ago i
bought a friend a carrot sharpener as a
gag gift and this seems to be
in the same product category as that
supposedly it makes it easier to cut
your bananas
which isn't something i was having
trouble with before but i guess this
would make it a little faster
who has a banana this large apparently
my local grocery store has bananas this
large
guess it's time to test this peel your
bananas from the bottom
that's what the monkeys do it's faster
hope it works
it does what it says it cuts the banana
and while it is definitely faster than
doing this with a knife
you can't control the width of the
slices and with all these grooves in
here it's gonna make it a little
harder to clean if i'm being honest this
thing is only seven dollars and if you
love slicing bananas or you want to get
it as a gag gift then
maybe it's for you but personally i
don't think i would use this
but i definitely am going to be putting
it in someone's stocking next year or
maybe as an ornament on their tree who
knows
[Music]
so the next two things i'm going to try
are very not safe for vampires so if
you're a vampire
don't buy these other people though uh
specifically those who
love garlic which should be all people
because garlic is a key component of
garlic bread and garlic bread is the
perfect food
thank you for coming to my ted talk
first up we have a garlic peeler and if
it works like it says it should
this might be a godsend because the
worst part of dealing with garlic
is peeling it even if you smash it with
a knife you still have to pull off the
peels and your hands get sticky
and if this does what it says i'll be a
very happy man
do i choose red or blue i'm going to
take some garlic cloves
pop them in here
oh my god
what that worked so well
it perfectly peeled the garlic and left
these super clean cloves without
any residue this is impressive
so this next tool takes the other most
annoying thing about garlic out of the
equation
it is the garlic zoom garlic chopper
supposedly
this tool makes it easy to chop a bunch
of garlic up
really fast open it up the top fill it
with
peeled garlic cloves roll it back and
forth
well damn that worked if you don't like
chopping garlic because it gets your
hands sticky and it makes your hands
smell like garlic
this worked really well and this guy's
so cute he's like a little star wars
droid
i'm gonna call him gg8 garlic garlic
eight
george lucas call me thumbs up i would
get this one
[Music]
last but far from least we got a smart
toaster
this is the revolution toaster from
revolution cooking it's a smart toaster
it has a six inch touchscreen on the
front where you select
what you're toasting and how dark you
want it to be and then
it toasts it i'm actually very excited
for this
it's so shiny okay bread it's fresh
bread
popping it in there let's say a medium
lightness
start it sucks it down in
and it has a little countdown timer on
it i've never been excited to watch a
toaster before
four three two
what
oh wow perfectly toasted i must say
that certainly is a piece of toast let's
try really dark bread
start i'm never gonna get over it
sucking down the bread like that
i know a toaster doesn't need a screen
but i cannot help but be
in awe of this i feel like i'm living in
a very mundane future
it does take the guesswork out of
toasting and as far as toasters go
this is probably like the best toaster
you're gonna get do i need a smart
toaster
no but am i gonna use this every single
day
absolutely oh very dark
once again exactly as i requested
so yeah you can get a lot of weird stuff
on the internet but it is interesting to
see that a lot of these are
actually worth their while and do
exactly as they
say they do whether what they say they
do is worth it to you
that's a personal thing i have to say my
favorite thing i tried out today though
was actually the garlic peeler of course
i'm gonna use the toaster more
frequently than anything but this garlic
peeler
was super handy let me know if you tried
or if you get any of these things down
in the comments below i'm curious to see
what you think of them and if there are
any gadgets you see on tick tock or
instagram
feel free to send them my way i will
gladly take a peek and
maybe check them out in another video
but for now
i've got some more toast to eat
you